Kenny put Lonnie Walker's night in
perspective for me
um
a prose Pro a guy who is
no you know who's keeping his
opportunities ready uh you know if
LeBron said it he said it but it's an
internal feeling that you know I there
was a couple I don't know if you guys
remember Danielle Don I think it was not
Daniel Marshall but Donnie Marshall that
went to Connecticut as well and I saw
him as a rookie and I said just because
you don't play don't mean you can't play
doesn't mean that and you know Lonnie
Walker it has been a really good player
you know I had the luxury obviously see
him in the summertime and I was like man
I didn't realize he was explosive to the
basket and then when the trades happened
they stopped playing them here he is
he's back
indeed and again first three quarters
tonight 15 minutes didn't take a shot
and then in the fourth quarter lights it
up uh for the Lakers with 15 and Lonnie
Walker joins us now after the Lakers
victory over the Golden State Warriors
Lonnie thanks a lot for taking the time
this is Ernie Johnson got Kenny Chuck
and Shaq here with me
put this into words man I mean this is
playoff basketball this stage that
quarter against the Champs where's your
mind right now
uh God is good you know first and
foremost I've been locked in been
staying in the gym and just waiting for
my opportunity this is something that
I've been dreaming with my entire life
and uh manifesting it and um with due
diligence and mental fortitude you know
I got to be able to show what I was
capable of doing
a lot of the close game you got greatest
player in the game LeBron James giving
you the ball how do you make the
decision I'm a shoot or I'm gonna get it
back to him how do you make the decision
on what you're going to do at that point
uh I mean personally I'm a three level
scorer you know the candle stainless I'm
a very confident player and if he's
instilling and passing me the ball and
letting me do what I got to do then I'm
always gonna make the right reads you
know so
um the fact that he gave me the trust um
I was just ready to play the best of my
capability
number one Lonnie congratulations you
were fabulous tonight when you when
you're not getting to play a lot and you
have to go work on your game in the gym
by yourself who's the person who's been
going with you to get rebounds working
on your condition and things like that
uh my brother's uh my boy Sergio my boy
Tyree Gibson and my father for the most
part you know we've been just locked
into the gym and just waiting you know
we we can't control the uncontrollables
but you know once my name my name and
number is called you know there's no
excuses I gotta be on that floor and be
a plus for my teammates
you know you know you know I think uh
Shaq and Charles may not have been able
to ever have this happen to them in
their career
uh for me I've been in that situation
once do you work out with a anger or do
you work out with a diligence or both
um internally probably both
um not anger on the sense of not being
able to play but anger on the sense that
no one knows who I am yet and understand
understanding my value and capability on
the floor
um so it comes with a lot of diligence a
lot of discipline but I've been doing
this for 24 years of my life I've always
been in the gym and nothing's ever going
to change so
um the the proof is in the put in the
harder you work the the more sacrifices
you make the better the outcome
Skywalker out of the U Lonnie Walker uh
one of these stories of this game is the
Lakers knock off the Golden State
Warriors appreciate your time man thank
you yes sir thank you great game brother
104 to 101 the Lakers over Golden State
and a 3-1 lead now foreign